dabei ist frau hast du bereits
angesprochen man sieht diese gefasste
tapfere frau die ja um die ausreise
ihres mannes aus russland gekämpft hat
und jetzt auch immer an seiner seite ist
sie kommt morgens sie geht abends was
macht sie für einen eindruck auf dich du
konntest du hier beobachten
ja was macht sie für den eindruck sie
ist sehr tapfer sie ist sehr gefasst
wenn man nach ihrer haltung gehen kann
hat sie natürlich das ganze leid jetzt
sie sitzt mehr als zehn stunden am tag
neben dem bett ihres mannes sie kommt
morgens früh unter polizeischutz in die
klinik sie geht ganz schnell rein lässt
sich kontrollieren setzt den mundschutz
auf und dann bleibt sie dort und dann
gestern abend ist sie um zehn nach
sieben aus der klinik herausgekommen
sofort kam sie auch unter polizeischutz
ließ dann abgeholt worden von freunden
vor der klinik und wird dann weggefahren
sie beantwortet auch keine fragen weil
sie sagte natürlich das wollen wir dann
in einer pressekonferenz machen aber man
merkt schon wie belastend und wie
furchtbar schlimm ist für die frau ist
die wirklich minütlich um das leben
ihres mannes mannes bank und sie kann
eben auch nur hoffen dass die charité
ärzte hier ihr bestes machen und
ansonsten wissen wir nicht viel was sie
macht sie kommt morgens geht abends weg
und wir hoffen alle dass sie heute eben
vor die presse tritt um eventuell dann
gute neuigkeiten zum gesundheitszustand
ihres mannes zu verkünden